retrouvez tout de suite notre
correspondante elena volochine qui se
trouve à belgorod y at il des réactions
de la population russe et notamment à ce
que vous savez si elle adhère à la
propagande du kremlin sur le fait que
l'ukraine est un pays d'asie ou pas
alors il ya une partie de la population
qui adhère effectivement à ce discours
celle qui regarde encore les chaînes de
télévision d'état et puis il ya cette
partie sans doute un des six qui ne veut
plus vraiment savoir ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui parce que on l'a maintes
fois évoqués dans les études
sociologiques les russes ne veulent pas
avoir le mauvais rôle ils veulent
toujours voir que la russie est du bon
côté de l'histoire que la russie fait le
bien alors pour ceux qui veulent avoir
ce rôle là mais qu'ils se rendent compte
se rendent bien compte aujourd'hui que
la russie est tout de même en train de
mener ce que vladimir poutine qualifie
d'opération militaire spéciale ou dans
d'autres discours qu'il qualifie de
opérations de pour ramener la paix et la
démocratie eh bien on a quand même le
sentiment ici qu'il se passe autre chose
que cela alors ils disent nous voulons
il faut bien imposer le bien par la
force il fallait cette opération alors
pourquoi parce que pendant des années la
propagande leur a martelé que en ukraine
il y avait un état nazi qui massacrer
les populations russophones de l'est du
pays pourquoi parce que à partir de 2014
il y avait ce conflit local entre les
républiques séparatistes créé par moscou
dit république de dounia très de
lougansk d'un côté suite à l'annexion de
la crimée et puis de l'autre côté le
gouvernement ukrainien qui a dit nous ne
laisserons pas prendre les républiques
de l'est de l'ukraine comme nous avons
laissé la crimée d'où ce conflit d'où
cette guerre qui aujourd'hui dégénère en
une année à dégénérer en une guerre
totale elena est ce qu'elles vont les
sanctions qui ont été prises qui sont
annoncés comme massive est ce que vous
pensez qu'elle vaut souder les russes la
population russe derrière vladimir
poutine ou est-ce que ça peut créer des
dissensions au sein du kremlin
alors avant de vous parler des sanctions
je voudrais juste si vous me permettez
dire un mot sur l'endroit où je me
trouve sur ce que j'ai vu il ya à peine
un instant parce que parce que nous
sommes sur la route en fait qui mène à
la frontière ukrainienne nous avons pu
nous rapprocher de l'autre côté là une
vingtaine de kilomètres derrière moi il
y à la frontière qui a été prise
d'assaut par la russie hier matin nous
avons entendu ces combats
et donc les relents l'armée russe est
entrée par cette frontière et nous nous
sommes rapprochés jusqu'à 10 kilomètres
de cette frontière est déjà un peu plus
loin il ya beaucoup moins de véhicules
civils - de réseaux aussi internet et
nous avons vu des colonnes toute la
machine nous avons observé en fait la
machine de guerre russe en train de se
diriger vers cette frontière est à dix
kilomètres donc il y avait la police
avec des gilets pare-balles et d'aider
des fusils kalachnikov qui arrêtait
toute les voitures civiles et laissez
passer nous avons vu passer ces colonnes
qui sans discontinuer vont vers
l'ukraine des tanks avec les tankistes
qui sont prêts en position de combat à
l'extérieur nous avons vu des missiles
grad aussi cette artillerie lourde qui
bombardent sans discontinuer ces cibles
et d'autres d'autres d'autres matches
d'autres artillerie très lourdes dont je
ne connais même pas les noms parce que
ce n'est pas ma spécialité mais vraiment
toute la machine de guerre russe qui est
en route vers cette frontière qui
n'arrête pas de rentrée depuis depuis
hier matin et depuis que cette frontière
a été prise et nous avons des
informations comme quoi la bataille de
la ville de kharkiv la deuxième plus
grande ville ukrainienne donc est en
train d'avoir lieu difficile d'avoir des
informations précises sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment on parle
d'encerclement sur les réseaux sociaux
nous essaierons de vérifier ses
informations un peu plus tard merci
beaucoup et léna volochine merci pour
votre analyse et toutes vos informations